[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous
vous regardez l'échiquier mondial sur rt
france l'année 2021 est déjà là mais
2020 a été si particulière sur tous les
plans que nous avons voulu y revenir
pour les 28 prochaines minutes afin de
comprendre à quoi ressemblera
l'échiquier géopolitique de demain
conflits régionaux économie au ralenti
et pandémie de coronavirus comment
l'année passée at elle au juste
bouleverser l'échiquier mondial
d'abord il ya des chiffres qui font
froid dans le dos plus de 1 million 700
mille morts dus aux copies de 19
la pandémie n'a épargné aucune région du
monde
les superpuissances mondiales elles ne
sont pas épargnés par une nouvelle
escalade de confrontation les états unis
et la chine sont allés presqu'au bout de
leur guerre diplomatique de nombreux
changements ont aussi changé la donne au
moyen-orient israël est reconnu par
plusieurs pays arabes et l'iran menace
de se désengager de l'accord sur le
nucléaire
l'europe elle fait face à des défis sans
précédent d'une part il faut réanimer
l'économique très vite sans mettre en
danger les citoyens
la turquie membre de l'otan est un autre
casse tête
erdan continue à jouer des muscles en
libye et dans les eaux chypriotes en
2020 un certain nombre de conflits
anciens se sont également réveillés à
travers le monde dont celui du haut
karabakh ou encore celui du sahara
occidental la libye semble faire figure
d'exception dans ce monde en évolution
là-bas le processus de paix a démarré et
pourrait bien mettre fin à la guerre
civile
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici des chiffres
clés qui ont marqué l'année passée c'est
le blitz en 2020 le pib mondial a
diminué de plus de 5% ce qui représente
la plus forte récession planétaire
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale le
nombre important depuis qu'ils se sont
retrouvés simultanément récession fait
de cette crise l'une des pires qu'ait
connu l'humanité depuis des années 1870
selon la banque mondiale celle ci
prévoit une diminution du revenu par
habitant de 3 6% ce qui risque de faire
basculer des millions de personnes dans
l'extrême pauvreté en une année toujours
selon la banque mondiale entre 88 et 115
millions de personnes de plus ont
commencé à vivre avec moins de 1 90
dollar par jour en 2020 le prix d'une
tasse de café dans les pays développés
la famine est une autre conséquence
lourde de cette année selon le programme
alimentaire mondial des nations unies
265 millions de personnes
supplémentaires pourraient avoir
souffert de la faim en 2020 cette crise
à la fois économique et humanitaire
risque en outre de pousser 9,7 millions
d'enfants hors de l'école sur 2020 le
magazine time lui met une croix
définitive en qualifiant cette année
deux pires de l'histoire une période en
tout cas difficile on a approché les
deux millions de morts duo kobe 19
on a dû porter des masques et à longueur
de journée on a vu l'économie être
emporté par une spirale infernale
la géopolitique a changé la donne aussi
ethiopie haut karabakh biélorussie ou
bien pérou les nouveaux foyers de guerre
et de tensions politiques sont comme des
plaies ouvertes sur la carte du monde
l'année 2020 a été aussi l'une des plus
difficiles dans les relations sino
américaines
kovy 19 hong kong ou gourou ou bien de
taiwan les sujets qui fâchent les deux
pays sont nombreux 2020 nain pas non
plus épargné le moyen-orient
l'assassinât du général iranien
soleymani la publication de l'accord du
siècle est la reconnaissance d'israël
par plusieurs pays arabes en europe
l'année passée a été marquée par la saga
breakbeat et les relations difficiles
avec la turquie alors comment
l'année 2020 at elle transformé la carte
géopolitique mondiale par quel événement
at elle été le plus marqué et quel rôle
tous ces événements vont-ils jouer en
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons georges et steven un
responsable des études européennes de
l'ip ce monsieur stievenart bonjour
bonjour le magazine time a qualifié 2020
de pires années de l'histoire
pourquoi un tel choix selon vous est ce
vraiment le cas
non écoutez on voit bien que le choix
est assez justifiée compte tenu de la
multiplicité des problèmes conflictuels
qui est et autres d'ailleurs y compris
l'épidémie de e.coli 19 qui ont affecté
le monde en 2020 mais dire que c'est la
pire année ça je crois que c'est une
forte exagération les pires années ce
sont celles où il ya un conflit mondial
et nous n'avons pas eu en 2020 un
conflit mondial porte heureusement et
quel événement a bouleversé l'échiquier
géopolitique le plus en 2020 selon vous
a écouté mouvement du monde et je veux
bien donner 2 je crois que les deux
principaux courts ça a été l'épidémie de
kovy évidemment et ça a été au niveau
américain les naisseurs de thomas est
venu à la présidence les états unis dans
les conditions que nous connaissons et
dont nous ne sommes pas encore
complètement en titre
ça ce sont deux ferait absolument majeur
le premier il est mondial parce qu'ils
affectent pratiquement le candide 19
affecté pratiquement tous les pays de la
planète à des degrés divers certes mais
tout de même de façon sensible à peu
près partout tandis que le problème de
changement de pouvoir
dans ces conditions aux états unis a
évidemment lui aussi des conséquences
sur les relations entre les états unis
et le reste du monde sur les relations
entre les états et enoch nouilles ici en
europe occidentale
on est évidemment particulièrement
concerné aussi par cette transition dont
on ne sait pas encore très bien sûr qu
il va déboucher
georges estimé à votre plus grande
déception votre plus grand regret
géopolitique en 2020 c'est quoi
écoutez mon plus grand regret je vais
vous dire je suis moi personnellement
depuis toujours très engagé dans la
construction européenne
nous avons eu en 2020 un certain rebond
de l'union européenne y compris hier
avec la signature finalement en tout cas
la définition d'un accord avec la grande
bretagne pour rendre le président à peu
près supportable pour les deux parties
ça ce sont des faits plutôt positif le
fait négatifs que je le vois en 2020 a
été la persistance en fait une relation
avec la russie qui n'est pas
satisfaisante entre l'union européenne
et la russie
nous restons dans un type de relation si
non conflictuelle du mois je dirai où il
ya un manque de confiance mutuelle qui
fait que de temps à autre on se retrouve
face à des problèmes non résolus aussi
bien qu'il s'agisse des conflits gelés
que leur nom en europe et autour de
l'europe ou bien qu'il s'agisse mais des
relations directes entre l'union
européenne et la russie
comme vous le savez les sanctions
européennes qui sont toujours en vigueur
vis-à-vis de la russie tout cela à la
longue
nina un peu les perspectives de
rapprochement nécessaire de mon point de
vue entre l'union européenne et la
russie qui dans le monde de demain
probablement on devoir constituer un
pôle cohérente
merci beaucoup monsieur stievenart nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse mais
nous retrouverons la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur le
thème merci encore virulent mal connus
contagieux est très rapide
le virus du coc vide 19 à changer la
face du monde
en l'espace de quelques mois apparue en
décembre 2019 dans la ville de wuhan en
chine
il nous apprend très vite ce que c'est
que le confinement généraliser les
fermetures des frontières l'état
d'urgence lé limitation des déplacements
les écoles fermées l'arrêt du trafic
aérien la fin de presque tous les
divertissements et les masques à
longueur de journée on aurait pu croire
à tort que le virus a fait une pause cet
été mais ce n'était que pour reprendre
des forces et frapper à nouveau
le bilan total de cette pandémie est
très lourde presque deux millions de
décès
sont enregistrés à travers le monde tous
les espoirs reposent désormais sur la
course au vaccin devenu un enjeu
commercial et géopolitique à la fois un
des leaders de cette compétition et la
russie qui enregistre le premier vaccin
anti qu'ovide en août le spoutnik v et
plus tard en deuxième
épinac corona la chine l a5 vaccins au
dernier stade des essais cliniques mais
la vaccination de masse ci poursuit déjà
depuis le mois de juillet l'autre acteur
de taille et washington qui accorde en
décembre sa première autorisation pour
le vaccin de l'alliance américano
allemande riser bintec une nouvelle que
donald trump cas les filles de réussite
historique pourtant sa propre gestion de
la pandémie lui a coûté des poids
politique
1 un terme plus de 18 millions de cas
détectés et plus de 300000 morts font
des états unis le pays le plus touché
par le coguic 19 situation qui a certes
entaché le bilan de donald trump dans
une campagne présidentielle qui ne
ressemble à aucune autre dans l'histoire
américaine
débat houleux insu accusations enfin
hospitalisation de donald trump lui même
testé positif aux copies 19 aux états
unis on ne fait pas les choses à moitié
le vote est un autre tour de magie des
résultats préliminaires donnent
initialement vainqueur donald trump
or le comptage des bulletins de vote par
correspondance permet à baden de
dépasser son adversaire trump accuse
alors le camp démocrate de fraude et se
lance dans une bataille juridique pour
contester les résultats
dans certains états un certain nombre de
chefs d'état ont envoyé leurs
félicitations à joe biden avant même que
ce résultat soit confirmée parmi eux le
président chinois xi jingping qui s'est
dit prêt au développement des relations
bilatérales qui ont pris à un coup dur
sous donald trump et surtout en 2020 à
partir de mars dernier
donald trump lance une offensive
diplomatique sans précédent contre la
chine
ils l'accusent d'avoir tardé à alerter
le monde sur l'épidémie est d'en avoir
dissimulé l'ampleur
l'autre sujet de discorde et hong kong
en juin 2020 pékin fait passer une loi
sur la sécurité nationale qui
renforce le contrôle chinois sur cette
région administrative spéciale
washington accuse alors la chine de
violation de l'autonomie hongkongaise et
adopte deux volets de sanctions contre
les responsables politiques chinois et
hong kong et dont la responsable de
l'exécutif
car il à pékin réplique un imposant ses
sanctions contre nombre de responsables
politiques américains ensuite vient la
question ungur se posant en défenseur de
cette minorité musulmane
d'administration de trump adopté une
série de sanctions visant une vingtaine
d'entités chinoise ainsi que plusieurs
hauts responsables supposément impliqué
dans la violation des droits des
ouïghours
la chine qualifie ces mesures d'
ingérence flagrante dans ses affaires
internes
une accusation qui s'applique aussi à la
politique américaine à l'égard de taiwan
plus particulièrement c'est la vente
d'armes à taipei camille pékin en colère
la chine adopte donc des sanctions
contre plusieurs entreprises de défense
américaine les sanctions américaines
quant à elles ont largement viser cette
année les entreprises chinoises de haute
technologie pourtant le coup le plus dur
a été portée aux géants des télécoms
chinois à savoir vous le connaissez tous
ou avait en mai 2001 la maison blanche
étant son embargo contre le géant des
télécoms chinois de nouvelles mesures
interdisent à toute entreprise étrangère
de lui vendre des puces électroniques
fabriqués à partir des technologies
américaines
cette interdiction est étendue plus tard
à 38 entreprises affiliées à ou avait
parallèlement l'administration preuve
appellent régulièrement ses alliés a
fermé la porte aux équipements 5g
chinois la suède et la roumanie est
longue déjà fait cette année et le
royaume uni banny l'installation des
nouvelles antennes fabriqués par ou avec
dès septembre 2021 trump est ferme avec
la chine par contre il ouvre une
nouvelle ère dans les relations israélo
arabe
le 15 septembre les émirats arabes unis
et bahreïn signe des accords de
normalisation avec israël sous la
médiation du président américain en
octobre c'est au tour du soudan de
mettre fin à l'état de guerre
avec l'état hébreu en échange le soudan
est retiré de la liste américaine des
états soutenant le terrorisme où il
figurait depuis 1993
enfin en décembre le maroc normaliser
ses relations avec israël
très vite washington reconnaît la
souveraineté de rabat sur le sahara
occidental
comment ces accords ont t'ils bouleversé
les anciennes alliances dans le monde
arabe
quels sont les conflits allumé en 2020
qui sont sur le point de s'éteindre
et quels sont ceux qui vont sûrement
perdurer la réponse après la pause 2020
aura littéralement changé la face du
monde le paysage géopolitique de
plusieurs grandes régions ne sera plus
jamais le même
et cette année aura aussi laissé en
suspens nombre de questions cruciales
pour la sécurité et la stabilité
mondiales qu'il est urgent de résoudre
tout d'abord l'année 2021 va être
marquée par de nombreuses élections la
république tchèque le kazakhstan ou
encore la russie vont organiser les
scrutins législatifs
alors que le tchad ou le chili vont
élire leur président une attention
particulière est pourtant porté cette
année aux élections législatives
allemandes
cela sera le premier scrutin depuis des
années où l'union chrétienne démocrate
ne sera pas dirigée par angela merkel
l'opposition est donc prête à saisir sa
chance et lance déjà les préparatifs
pour la campagne à la succession de la
chancelière l'autre élection décisive
qui va marquer l'année en cours et celle
qui va se tenir en iran le président
actuel hassan rohani ne va pas se
représenter au scrutin le candidat de
son camp dit modéré sera désigné en 2021
mais pourra-t-il remporter l'élection
compte tenu du bilan mitigé de rois ni
enfin les japonais éliront leurs députés
en automne 2021
la plus grande question qui se pose est
de savoir si le parti libéral démocrate
présidé par yoshi et des sugar
va rester au pouvoir pas sûr en fait
selon un sondage réalisé fin décembre
2020 la cote de popularité du cabinet du
premier ministre
yoshi des sugar est tombé à 40 2 %
d'ailleurs l'année en cours pourrait
marquer un tournant important dans le
conflit libyen en cours depuis plusieurs
années après l'offensive du chef de
l'armée nationale libyenne à l'ifa
haftar sur tripoli et une contre attaque
des forces du gouvernement d'union
nationale présidé par fayez al sa rage
les deux camps signe en octobre 2020 un
cessez le feu sous médiation de l'onu
démarre ensuite un dialogue entre les
représentants de toutes les forces
politiques du pays qui débouche sur un
certain nombre d'accords l'organisation
des élections législatives et
présidentielle le 24 décembre 2021 et le
transfert du pouvoir exécutif à deux
institutions transitoires
cette trêve est qualifié par l'onu d'
historique mais pourra-t-elle aboutir à
la transition politique
2021 pour être aussi faire bouger les
lignes dans le conflit ukrainien depuis
la dernière rencontre au format
normandie en 2019 pas de grande avancée
dans la mise en place des accords de
minsk cadre principal du règlement de la
crise
la réforme constitutionnelle n'a pas eu
lieu la loi sur le statut spécial du
donbass n'a pas été adopté pourtant en
automne les deux côtés du conflit
annoncent leur plan de sortie de la
crise
le compromis est il possible étant donné
le grand nombre de divergences en
parlant de l'avenir du conflit ukrainien
il faut certes tenir compte de l'arrivée
au pouvoir aux états unis du candidat
démocrate joe biden ardent défenseur de
l'ukraine et l'a promis lors de sa
campagne une importante aide financière
à kiev et des livraisons d'armes
d'une manière plus générale sa politique
internationale va rappeler celle d'obama
le retour dans les organisations et
accords multilatéraux la coopération
plus étendue avec les
les traditionnels américains la pression
sur la chine via des alliances
régionales
quant à la russie by donne la qualifie
de principale menace aux états unis et
promet d' agir plus fermement que son
prédécesseur
dans ce contexte la victoire du candidat
démocrate renforcent l'incertitude
autour du gazoduc nordstream deux
terminé à plus de 90% ce projet de
gazoduc reliant la russie et l'allemagne
a été brutalement interrompue fin 2019
après les sanctions américaines les
autorités russes ont alors promis de
terminer la construction par leurs
propres moyens en 2021
la reprise des travaux est annoncée en
décembre 2020 ce projet pourra-t-il être
lancée en 2021
sachant qu'il en reste encore près de
150 kilomètres de tuyaux à poser quelle
sera la position de joe biden sur israël
et le plan de paix avec la palestine
c'est aussi l'une des grandes questions
de 2021
le plan de paix israélo-palestiniennes
de donald trump le deal du siècle est
née début 2020 pourtant il est aussitôt
rejeté par les palestiniens comme trop
favorable à israël
le président mahmoud abbas refuse de le
négocier et même de le lire puis rond
dans toute relation avec tel-aviv et
washington
les tensions montent d'un cran avec la
normalisation entre israël et plusieurs
états arabes les palestiniens accusent
les pays musulmans de trahison et
rappellent leurs ambassadeurs à abu
dhabi et à bahreïn en 2020 plusieurs
confrontations éclate à la frontière
entre israël et gaza les pays voisins
craignent un potentiel conflit
d'ailleurs au début de l'année le
moyen-orient a déjà frôlé un conflit
militaire entre les etats-unis et l'iran
l' escalade remonte à la fin de 2019
plusieurs attaques visent à l'heure des
bases américaines en irak
les tirs ne sont pas revendiqués mais
washington pointe du doigt les milices
chiites et les rangs en réponse le 3
janvier 2020 un raid américain tue le
plus en général iranien qassem suleimani
8 janvier téhéran riposte en frappant
deux bases américaines en irak
des deux côtés les menaces se
multiplient les principales cibles
américaines dans la région sont depuis
longtemps identifié par l'iran quelques
35 d'entre elles sont à notre portée de
même que tel aviv une guerre ouverte
n'aura pas lieu mais il ya d'autres
terrains d'affrontement au moyen-orient
qui saignent les pays aussi bien de
l'extérieur que de l'intérieur
l'irak reste en proie à des
manifestations violentes contre la
corruption en mars et avril deux
premiers ministres démissionnent de
suite
cependant la révolte continue contre
leurs successeurs scénario similaire au
liban les manifestations anti
gouvernementales ne cesse depuis 2019
la colère populaire atteint son pic
début août après l'explosion
dévastatrice à beyrouth le premier
ministre
hassan diab démissionne crise politique
nouveau premier ministre à l'ancienne
saad hariri une économie au bord du
gouffre c'est ainsi que 2020 se termine
pour le liban en algérie la contestation
persiste aussi le mouvement du irak
continue de réclamer un démantèlement du
système et boycottent le référendum
constitutionnel en novembre 2020 a aussi
ouvert de nouvelles plaies régional qui
cette fois ci se sont transformés en
conflit ouvert
en ethiopie le gouvernement s'opposent
aux forces de la région de tigres et qui
aspire à l'indépendance début novembre
c'est un band sans les séparatistes
attaque l'armée éthiopienne en moins
d'un mois les forces gouvernementales
écrase la rébellion les affrontements
font jusqu'à 10000 morts selon certaines
estimations
l'autre conflit marquant de 2020 oppose
l'arménie à l'azerbaïdjan autour du haut
karabagh l'arménie défend le droit de la
région à l'autodétermination mais
l'azerbaïdjan la considère comme sa
province
après quinze ans de trêve les hostilités
reprennent fin septembre ce conflit
devient un vrai carrefour des intérêts
régionaux
l'azerbaïdjan est appuyée par la turquie
ce qui cause l'inquiétude des états unis
et de la france
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise réussi à
reprendre le contrôle de plusieurs
territoires le
c'est le feu conclu sous l'égide de la
russie qui instaure une mission
militaire de maintien de paix les
arméniens se sentent trahis par l'issue
du conflit dans le haut karabakh et
descendent dans la rue pour exiger la
démission du premier ministre arménien
nikol pashinian les manifestations
frappe aussi la moldavie où les choses
bougent
maya sans doute candidat de l'opposition
remporte la présidentielle cependant le
bloc pro-russe au parlement lui fait de
la résistance la nouvelle vague de
contestations politiques envahi la la
pologne elle s'enflamme aussi en octobre
après les nouvelles restrictions majeur
au droit de l'avortement
les manifestations rassemblent plus de
cent mille personnes en biélorussie la
contestation est aussi massive depuis
août
l'opposition dénonce les résultats de la
présidentielle et exige un nouveau vote
équitable
aucun guide tant l'issue des
législatives provoquent de véritables
révolte dans le pays
résultat le scrutin est annulée et
reportée au janvier le président
démissionne un ancien ministre
libéré de prison prend sa place
néanmoins le champion d'extravagance et
le pérou après la destitution du
président vizcarra trois chefs d'état
lui succède en une semaine
un autre défi hérité de 2020 façonnera
sûrement en profondeur la diplomatie
européenne
cette année la turquie se montre de plus
en plus active en méditerranée elle
explore des hydrocarbures dans les eaux
revendiquées par l'union européenne plus
précisément ceux de la république de
chypre
les sanctions tombent mais air douanes
passe au chantage et menacent d'inonder
le de migrants le dossier les biens
accumule aussi des tensions bruxelles
dénonce les livraisons d'armes turque à
tripoli en violation de l'embargo de
l'onu
entre temps les tensions grand entre
ankara et paris
la crise diplomatique tournant brouille
personnel entre matheron et redonne tout
ce qu'on peut dire d'un chef d'état qui
traitent des millions de membres de
communautés religieuses différentes de
cette manière c'est aller d'abord faire
des examens de santé mentale
la turquie se transformera-t-elle en
mauvaise élève de l'otan les
partenariats historiques seront ils
disent
où et comment les changements de 2020
vont-ils peser dans la géopolitique de
cette nouvelle année pour comprendre ce
qui nous attend 2021 nous revenons vers
george et steven un responsable des
études européennes de l'ip ce monsieur
et stephen a parlons maintenant de
l'année qui est devant nous beaucoup
d'experts disent qu'en 2021 nous serons
au seuil d'un nouvel ordre mondial à
cause du corona virus et d autres
facteurs est ce vrai selon vous si oui
en quoi consistera ce nouvel ordre
alors oui en effet dans la ligne droite
de ce que nous disions intérieurement je
crois que le phénomène du convient de
dire 9 a secoué fortement la communauté
internationale et la communauté mondiale
alors donc 2021 qu'est ce que ça va être
ça va être d'une part la poursuite de la
pandémie la pandémie n'est toujours pas
maîtrisé en cette fin d'année et il va
falloir y parvenir on espère le plus tôt
possible dans l'année mais nous partons
au moins pour six mois encore de
difficultés face pays par pays continent
par continent
face à cette pandémie ça c'est un très
gros problème
derrière ce très gros problème pas
d'ailleurs en arriver un deuxième qui
est utile ou qui sont les conséquences
économiques de la pandémie
c'est à dire des pans entiers des
économies des différents pays surtout
les plus affectées et dieu sait que
c'est le cas en europe occidentale ces
deux cas aux états unis
c'est le cas au brésil c'est le cas dans
de nombreux pays un peu moins et même
beaucoup moins en chine et en russie
mais en tout cas dans tous ces pays il
va y avoir de l'impact
je dirais le ricochet n'est ce pas de
lakovic 19 en 2021
et là il va falloir se restructurer
économiquement et ça a aussi un impact
sur la coopération et sur les échanges
internationaux
bien évidemment ça ça me paraît être le
plus gros problème devant nous
l'autre problème devant nous c'est de
voir comment
avec l'arrivée de durba l'éden à la
présidence des états unis
comment les états unis vont finalement
se positionner l'année prochaine par
rapport au reste du monde
je crois personnellement que on aurait
tort de penser que l'arrivée de joe
biden c'est le retour à la période
obama joe biden va évidemment devoir
tenir compte de ce qui s'est passé
pendant toutes la présidente août la
présidente de donald trump et ça ça ne
peut pas se traduire par si vous voulez
un simple retour en arrière l'année 2020
a vu aussi re surgir de vieux conflits
comme celui du haut karabakh
faut-il s'attendre à de nouveaux
conflits en 2021 si oui lesquels
alors écoutez moi je ne suis pas devin
donc je ne sais pas je ne sais pas où de
nouvelles crispations vont pouvoir
apparaître ce qui est évident c'est que
nous avons en quelque sorte des abcès
non fermées dans le monde qui veut pas
les cités un par un mais il y en a un
certain nombre ce qu'on appelle les les
conflits gelés qui peuvent qui peuvent
ressurgir
et puis il y a des partenaires aussi
ils ont tendance à s'agiter nous par
exemple au niveau européen nous avons de
fortes préoccupations et par l'évolution
interne et externe de la turquie de la
situation en turquie qui on a bien vu en
méditerranée commence à avoir des
positions préoccupante et qui l'amène à
sinon gérer des conflits au moins à
susciter dernier comment jeudi des
inquiétudes et des préoccupations au
niveau européen alors tout cela ce sont
des éléments qui évidemment dont on ne
sait pas très bien s'il vont se
développer ou s'ils vont se résorber
moi j'espère qu'ils vont se résorber
mais pour cela encore une fois il faudra
beaucoup d'intelligence de patience et
de coopération internationale
c'est en tout cas ce que je souhaite
pour l'europe et je souhaite pour notre
grand voisin qu'est la russie
encore une fois avec laquelle nous
n'avons pas les relations jusqu'à
présent qu'ils sont à la hauteur des
enjeux géopolitiques mondiaux merci
beaucoup
georges et stievenart pour votre analyse
vous rappelle vous êtes responsable des
études européennes de lips merci encore
d'avoir participé à cette émission
cette partie n'est pas encore terminé
l'année 2000 21 ne fait que commencer la
semaine prochaine une nouvelle partie
nous attend avec d'autres pions sur
l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]